hi so I'm in this talk call me i'll be
speaking about the the data civil from
data science platform and doing data
science in the cloud with it i will very
quickly place it in the context of the
other cloud platforms that we have
developed are developing an hour coming
out soon and i'll give you a little bit
of motivation for doing data science in
the cloud in the first place and the
kind of problems that this is expected
to solve and why you should care about
having a cloud-based data science
platform in the first place after that
i'll give you a demonstration of the the
workflow using the data science platform
using a couple different data sources
okay so we started putting out these
cloud platforms starting earlier this
summer when the Wolfram programming
cloud came out the emphasis in this
particular platform is on programming on
developing applications and deploying
them and on helping small teams and
startups collaborate on them very soon
will be coming out with with Mathematica
online where the emphasis is on
extending the the desktop Mathematica
experience into the cloud if you saw the
keynote yesterday Stephen Wolfram also
mentioned the Wolfram discovery platform
for research and development and you
mentioned that the programming lab so
the data science platform is very much
in this family of stuff the emphasis in
it is on this sort of canonical data
science import analyze publish workflow
and you might reasonably ask you know
why would you want to do this in the
cloud and maybe I'm perfectly happy
doing my data science on the desktop I
think part of the answer is
collaboration and to some extent that's
true of any sort of cloud application
but more of it more of it has to do with
accessibility and reach and let me
explain what I mean by way of analogy
with computation so so funny things
happen we're finding that funny things
happen when you clarify notions even
long-standing notions from from from a
desktop paradigm so one notion is is the
the notion of the function so you may
have seen this yesterday the notion of
an API function an API function is a
cloud version of a normal function this
particular one expects our country is
input and it's going to output a map of
that country as an image
and if I want to I can run this on the
desktop so there's no cloud involved
here I'm getting a map of a country from
that function but interesting things
hard to start to happen when I deploy
this to the cloud I get a URL back and I
can use this URL to invoke the code
that's in that that's in that API
function so here I've asked my browser
to go out to the cloud make a request in
the Wolfram cloud and it serves back
this image to me so my browser doesn't
know or care what the technology stack
up there was it just got this image back
so in this case it was a browser it
could have been an app on my phone it
could be anything that makes an HTTP
request so ten years ago one year ago a
couple of months ago if I had given you
a piece of Wolfram language code and
said could you please execute this for
me your answer would have been no I
don't have Mathematica but you don't
have that excuse anymore I I don't have
that excuse because I can publish tough
as an API function and you don't have
that excuse because you have a web
browser and you can make sure HTTP
requests so you know software
futurologist have been saying for a long
time that the cloud is going to make
platforms relevant is going to please
everybody on a level playing field and
that's sort of happening for a Wolfram
language stuff so that's what happens
for computation so my claim is that when
this happens for other things it has
benefits for data science and one of the
things that that change is quite a bit
is or one of the things that has
benefits for is for computable documents
so if you've never if you have limited
experience or no experience playing with
the Wolfram system the the principal
interface to it is manipulating these
computable documents so these are these
are these are notebooks that that can
contain data formatted text typeset
mathematics code interactive elements
here you're looking at a chapter from a
calculus textbook here you're looking at
a medley of some entries in the wolfram
demonstrations project here you're
looking at a report compiled for the
state of Texas on the economics of
buying certain kinds of disaster
insurance and so on so in my opinion
these computable documents have been one
of the best arguments for doing data
science with Wolfram stuff in the first
place but they've had the disadvantage
that they are only as effective as the
decision-makers ability to consume the
format so it's become a distressingly
common story that you talk to somebody
who has done this wonderful analysis
worked up this wonderful analysis in a
notebook and you say well what happened
you showed that to your bosses and he
says well they don't have Mathematica
and they couldn't open it and you say
well couldn't they download the free CDF
player and and he says well IIT didn't
let us do that and you say oh okay so
now the excuse for this is disappearing
too because we've codified the idea of
having computable documents and so these
just open a web browser now and and and
and the the you know the destination
platform is becoming irrelevant and
we're finding that this is true in
smaller ways for all kinds of things as
we clarify them so concepts like so the
second most common story i think is
that's a great report can i get that
every week now on the desktop that's a
hard problem in the cloud it's actually
pretty easy and the reason it's pretty
easy is because we've had this notion of
scheduled tasks which has been sitting
around in Mathematica since version 8
when you clarify that idea you get
something like cron right you can run
things on the server on a regular
schedule so the idea of distributing
your report suddenly becomes very easy
and running it automatically okay so
this is my claim about why you should
care about having a cloud data science
illusion okay so let me show you what
the platform actually looks like and do
a couple things with it so I'm going to
take the URL of a data of a data source
and I'm going to flip over to my web
browser and show you the homepage of the
data science platform itself because
this is the homepage of it these four
big red buttons across the top
are commonly used channels for getting
data into the system in the first place
so I whether from connecting to an
external data source importing it from a
URL choosing a data data file that you
already have in the cloud or uploading
something from wherever you are so if I
if I was if I were going to upload
something I would you know I would I
would do something like this in this
case I'm going to import some data from
a URL so what is this data source this
is an online spreadsheet that I keep of
utilities usage at my house okay so
what's happening right now so the
platform took my data source and it's
preparing a notebook for me a computable
document which is seeded with some code
to help me start doing an analysis now
this is a special kind of notebook
called a template notebook you can
recognize it by these buttons across the
top there's nothing scary or special
about this so if I if I'm in the desktop
these exist too okay and what these what
these buttons do is they allow you to
create variables called slots in your
template which are filled in with
whatever you want to fill them in with
when you generate a document from this
template so for example I can give this
slot the default value of 42 and then
when I generate a document from this
template it will that that slot will be
filled in with that value okay so that's
the fundamental operation behind these
that's a fundamental idea behind these
templates and they exist in the cloud
they've been clarified to so what I'm
going to do with this notebook is start
working up an analysis and when I'm
happy with it when it's to the point
where it can produce a document that
someone else that I want someone else to
look at that's that's a reasonable thing
to give it to someone else including
myself I'm going to deploy it in the
same way that I deployed that API
function and and and schedule it to
generate those documents from this
template that I'm working on now okay so
how do I start well I can import the
data and I'm not only going to import
the data I'm going to semantically
import the data so semantic import is
this new function that you may have seen
yesterday in the
note it not only does the mechanics that
all the mechanics that import used to do
of getting the file into memory for you
but it also tries to recognize things in
such a way that they become interesting
and useful to human beings so for
example in this data set my first column
has the date the dates the dates appears
just just just as strings and the
original data set but here they've been
recognized as entities and and will
behave intelligently when I do things
like try to plot using that column
similarly columns that had monetary
value x values and them US dollar
quantities are recognized as such and
are given units okay so this thing that
I got back all right is called a data
set and it's it has its own sort of rich
query language associated with it and
that sort of its own talk but but using
this you can slice it using this data
set you can slice and dice data and
start doing visualizations with it so
you can imagine sort of fast forwarding
two hours when I've had a chance to to
work up some visual visualizations based
on this data I might wind up with a
template that looks like this okay so in
this version of the template which is
fast forwarded a couple hours I've done
some clean up I've excluded a line from
the original set that included that was
that was duplicated and I've started
doing visually visualizations like this
time series plots of my electricity and
gas usage and then other more
complicated stuff including forecasting
and doing things like time series model
fit so I can figure out what my
utilities bill is going to be next month
okay so when I'm happy with this I'm
going to deploy this as an automated
report this is the same kind of
deployment that I did of that API
function from the desktop and in this UI
there are all kinds of little dials and
knobs that I can twiddle I can choose
the output format of the that I want the
report to be that I want the report to
have I can specify specified recipients
for it I can specify attachment formats
for those recipients I can set a
schedule let's set this to run at the
end of the month since that's when I
tend to get my
bill I can create this thing and it's
going to show up in my list of reports
here now I can I don't have to wait for
the end of the month I can ask for it to
run right now when I do that the cloud
is spinning up the Machine necessary
machinery to apply this template and
then archive the generated document and
mail it to whoever needs to be mailed to
make it available to offer to whoever
asked for it while we're waiting for
that notification I can show you the
results of a previous run okay so this
is this is the result of applying the
template that we were just looking at
you can see my gas usage peaking in the
winter my electricity usage speaking in
the summers you can see distributions of
my electricity and gas usage you can see
the same distributions broken out by
season summer and winter you can see a
little bit of forecasting data here's my
combined electricity and gas usage
here's the combined electricity and gas
bill along with a 12-month forecast
according to the results of a time
series model fit which creates I think
ass ARIMA model of my utilities usage so
I'm on the hook for something like this
116 dollars this month okay so you can
there you can imagine taking this
further in all kinds of ways the next
thing I would probably do is compare the
last month's forecast with this month's
actual bill and see how my models are
actually doing but at this point you you
get a sense of what the end and workflow
is you start with you start with a blank
screen not having any data in the system
you pointed at some data you get it in
there you do the semantic import you
fiddle around with your data until you
get something you like and then you
deploy this thing which can which can be
sent to a decision maker including
yourself yeah question beg your pardon
you can we don't have any encryption per
se on the on the results but you can
control there's very fine-grained
permissions control on the on the output
so so you don't of course you don't
necessarily want all these URLs to be
wide open so if you want to share them
with only specific users you can let me
show you another example which which
showcases semantic import a bit more so
this is acute data set this is an
inventory of trees in in champaign
illinois where I live this is this is
done by the city so what you get in this
data set well here you here are the
columns you get a tree species and a
common name and a couple of figures
about the size and shape of the tree and
then you get a location in latitude and
longitude so when you semantically
import this thing the species are
actually recognized as plants that's one
of the things that semantic import
can-can recognized can recognize and and
plants have almost 150 properties that
that can be queried and are available to
you in your analysis for example you can
if you're curious you can confirm that
the foliage colour of a red maple is in
fact green okay you may also notice that
the latitudes and longitudes have been
identified as geo positions and this
makes them very handy for for for
mapping as we'll see in the end in the
template so you can imagine doing the
same thing that we just did with the
utilities data and working up a template
based on this based on this data here is
one you here's a semantic import of that
data set this template is going to do
some very basic data sciency stuff like
compiling a top 5 list of the most
common trees in the set it's going to
build a map of where the trees actually
are and then it's going to do some
filtering on particular species so we
can deploy this using the exact same
mechanism that I was just showing you
going through this UI giving it a name
specifying recipients and formats and so
on let me show you the results of a
of a previous run okay so here's the
results of applying that template red
maples are the most common tree and
almost one in eight trees in the cities
is a is a red maple here's the list with
thumbnails these thumbnails came out of
the are one of the entity properties so
we got them for free we didn't have to
do any work and we can make a map to so
here's here's a push pin map of a sample
of the trees in the city colored by
species I had no idea there were so many
distinct species of tree in the town so
this is a little bit overwhelming here's
here's a map with the results filtered
to ash trees only now I was curious
about this because in the in Illinois
and in many parts of the US ash trees
are being eaten by these guys emerald
ash borers this data set didn't contain
any information on six trees so I
simulated some ok so I simulated an
outbreak of ash borer disease and I and
I colored the sick trees red ok so
here's here's the map of the simulated
ash borer outbreak on the west side of
town here about two miles from wolfram
research headquarters so you can imagine
if you you know if you work for the
parks department in the city this would
be a useful thing to have in your inbox
every Monday morning to see what's
happening to the to the spread and and
and and i hope the sort of reinforces
this this this this conceptually very
simple workflow of getting in data
making a template and then producing a
document ok ok and we have lots more
examples of we have lots more examples
of these kinds of reports and producing
them and if you're interested in in
particular verticals or particular
aspects of producing them and what they
can do you know things like encryption i
encourage you to speak to me and and i
can get into more detail about them one
of the things that we think very hard
about is that is the language design
this is a primary consideration for us
so if there is something in the GUI that
you cannot do with the language it
usually means that we've made a mistake
and as your experience with these
systems grows you tend to move from
clicking your way through them to
scripting your way through them so did
just to give you a sin
of what that looks like here's an
example of a report that is scripted and
deployed completely from the desktop so
i don't have to touch the cloud at all
to get to a deployed thing that is
running automatically up in the cloud so
what is this one doing this is going to
fill in a template that looks like this
so this is a magnify that a bit so this
is a stock report the input of this
thing is going to be a list of financial
instruments in the output is going to be
some statistics about them presented in
presented in little interactive
manipulates okay so that's a template
I'm going to use this particular report
is interested in locating the top five
members of the trucking sector by
yesterday's trading volume and then
compiling a stock report on that ok so
this code that just gives you a sense of
the code of the code investment involved
in doing that kind of logic that's all
encapsulated here you can see this
financial built in financial data packet
that is doing the business of finding
out what the truck what finding out what
the members of the trucking sector are
and finding out what the volume was
yesterday and so on the actual
deployment of this report is done here
where we specify the template and the
schedule that we want to use in a couple
of options so when I execute this thing
all of this logic in this template are
being shoved up into the cloud and being
deployed is one of those things that the
net effect of this is exactly what it
was through the UI when I press the big
red deploy button on the website and and
I can tell this thing to run and in the
meantime I'll show you the results of a
previous report using this using this
template okay so these are the top five
stocks in the trucking industry by
yesterday's trading volume and then here
are some more details about each of them
okay so the takeaway here is that this
was done completely from the desktop I'm
the the the the scripting of this was
done completely from the desktop the
interactive elements in the output
document survive
survived into the generated document and
they're available even in the cloud ok
so here I am in the cloud examining the
output and and these these manipulates
are still operational ok so this gives
you a sense of how sort of fleet and how
easy it is to to prepare these sort
these sorts of reports you know if if
you if you have to maintain situational
awareness about lots of different things
in your job and you quickly need a
report about a thing that you haven't
considered before this is sort of the
speed with which you can spin these
things up ok I myself it I'm
particularly excited about the data
science platform because it's because of
the way that it solves these
accessibility problems that have
historically that has a sort
historically played using using more
from stuff for data science for the most
part they're just sort of melting away
and this is good this is this is going
to be a good thing and and and this is
you know this is happening in the short
to this is happening now in the short
term in the longer term I'm excited
about the ability potentially to do to
make to elastically make computing
resources available to the data science
job now that's something that we
couldn't that we could only really dream
about on the desktop on in the cloud
though it's it's it's gettin it's gettin
very close and using our experience with
grid computing and so on I think that
will happen in the medium term if you
have any questions about what this thing
can do we anticipate that at a launch in
a matter of months if you have questions
about what it can do if you just like to
tell me what your needs and requirements
are we love to gather stories and would
like to talk to you you can talk to me
you know here for the rest of the
conference you can feel free to send me
email afterwards as well and we also
have three team members at the
conference I claytonjeremy and Deepak
who would also be glad to be buttonholed
thank you